[音楽]
費を続けて30時間です最終手段取るしか
ない
[音楽]
なほら君の大好きなうまい棒だ欲しいか
いそれにコーラもあるよ
欲しいなら全部話してもらおうかなぜ君は
女トイレに入ったんだそれ
は
けけけ最近フォートナイトも強くなりすぎ
てやり応えがない
な
[音楽]
はい初めまして天才小学生す君今から君と
ゲームをするののに爆弾を仕掛けた君の
その頭脳を使って解除してみろ誰だよ
こんなずらしたのまさか本当にある
わけあっ
たまどうせおもちゃだろゲームやろっと
よいしょ行け行けけけ
けけけ
え次の設置場所は
女子
トイレ本当に女子トイレに爆弾があるのか
やだとしてもさすがに女子トイレはまずい
ん
じゃしよいい
[音楽]
よ疲れたほらお水飲みなよありがとう
ああ遠慮せずにもっと飲みなえ
ありがとうこれでこじりをトイレに向かわ
せて爆弾があるか確認しようはいダサお猿
はラゾ門を描いて有名になったんですよね
はあ全くトイレに行く気配がないもう俺が
行くしかない
えせ先生とトイレお前は先生をトイレ
みたいに汚ない人間だといたのか違います
トイレき
[音楽]
ますやすあいついつ帰ってくん
だ先生トイレだから先生はトイレじゃな
いって言ってるだろ
あれ誰か入ってるのああ漏れちゃう漏れ
ちゃう漏れ
[音楽]
ちゃう開けて開けてっ
つばあ
やー違うこれはどうしてこっちにドアを
開けたらやすが入ってたんですこの変小学
生が警察に行くぞほら行くぞささと
立それで女子トイレに入ったと
はい大人を飲めるなよそんな作り死か連れ
て
お
入れいらっしゃい君は何の罪で捕まったの
かな女子トイレに入ったことによる建造物
侵入罪見た目の割りにワルなことするね
あんたは覗きみさ実は昔から投資ができる
特殊能力があってねちなみに君のパンツは
黒え本当に分かるのま本当はズボがけた
からってあげるんだけどね
あ悪る待って本当だって見てく信じて
くれ面会の時間
[音楽]
だ助いい加減罪を認めただ罪も何も悪い
ことはしてませんお前男らしくないぞ先生
だって男だから女子イをきたくなる分かる
実際に覗いたこともある恥ずかしいこと
じゃないんだだからしっかりと罪を認めて
反省して帰ってこいやす俺もお前の味方な
や君のぶりけもういいよ帰って
くれ先生と友達もわざわざ来てくれたのに
まだ認めないの
か君の大好きなスイッチもできないままだ
よだからやってないラしてやるなんだて
俺に
任せろまずはあのシールドを解除しない
[音楽]
とでき
た落ち着け
落ち着けそうあれにかけてみるしかない
おいあんた投資できるんだろ来て
くれこの赤と青の同然どっちが爆発を
引き起こすものか投資してくれどれ
どれ赤だ
ね爆発を引き起こす同が赤なら
だが俺の直感が言ってる赤を切れ
[音楽]
と止まったよくやったぞ
あやったく先生の仕掛けで終えたカメラの
映像を見たら確かにお前は爆弾を処理して
い
た君の話を信じてあげられなくて悪かった
ま終わった話なので別にいいですよさあ
一緒に帰ろう待てお前は察の趣ほら行くぞ
さいてかお前間違えてたじゃんあれ間違え
ちゃったよそれにしても一体誰がこんな
こと
をおこの前の少年じゃんあ投資の人じゃん
今日のパンツは黒いや
ああれ今日調子悪い
なまた一緒にしようね天才小学生君まさか
お前
が一体何だったん
だちゃちゃちゃちゃチャンネル登録
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録よろしく
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録チャンネル
登録よろしく最初はグチャンネル登録
じゃけ登録またねOK